Welcome everyone.
Today we're excited to welcome founder and CEO of Doak you confections.
Kristen Tomlin.
Welcome.
Thank you.
And 2014 Kristen decided to officially launch doe as she uncovered a market of
cookie dough lovers in the world,
just psych herself.
They increase in demand soon.
Prompted Kristen to open her first brick and mortar experience here in New York
City in 2017 since Kristen has been a nominee of Crain's 40 under 40 and receive
brand praise my own publications such as the New York Times o,
the Oprah magazine people and across show is such as today.
And CBS this morning.
Today Kristen has developed over a hundred handcrafted flavors,
including top sellers such as signature chocolate chip,
which is my favorite cake batter,
heavenly and confetti,
some of which she will showcase here at Google today.
So how did doe start?
Like where did this idea come from?
So I had been a cookie dough lover my entire life.
Um,
I learned the INS and out of the kitchen from my mom who is a baker and a chef.
I grew up in Saint Louis,
so from the Midwest,
um,
and we made everything from scratch.
And so cookies,
we're no different.
We,
um,
you know,
I would love sharing just anything sugary with others for birthdays or any
occasion.
Um,
and anytime that we baked cookies at home,
it was a requirement to save my dad a Tupperware container of cookie dough so
that when he came home and saw the fresh baked cookies on the counter,
he immediately went to the fridge and got the cookie dough.
And even though we weren't supposed to eat cookie dough,
it was worth the risk for me growing up.
And it just continued to be kind of a secret obsession of mine.
You know,
throughout college I always had a tub of,
you know,
Toll House or whatever I could get my hands on.
Um,
and even after college I was continuing to bake.
I was working here in New York City,
um,
and I treated cookie dough,
like it was ice cream.
So I would keep some in my fridge at all times and take it out,
you know,
by the spoonful a little bit.
And then stick the container back.
So that was my experience with cookie dough.
But I came up with the idea for doe when I was with a bunch of girlfriends.
We were visiting a friend in graduate school at Villanova and we happened to go
to this cookie shop and they had a ton of fresh baked cookies and all sorts of
flavors.
And I had wandered over to their freezer section and they were selling their
cookie dough and chocolate chip for you to of course go home and bake.
But I turned to my friends and said,
hey,
well anybody split this with me?
I kind of just want the cookie dough and said,
no.
Everybody decided to just walk out of there without buying anything that was
actually baked.
And at that time it wasn't really acceptable to like sit in their cute little
shop and eat the cookie dough from the container.
So sat in the car and then,
you know,
we continued on with our shopping or whatever we were doing and we are,
are we going to get sick?
Are we going to feel terrible later?
Um,
we didn't really care.
We just finished the whole thing,
you know,
licking our fingers.
No shame.
Um,
good girlfriends.
And um,
and that was the moment we were in the car.
And I thought,
why isn't this a thing?
Why can't you go to a store and just eat the cookie dough?
We all just wanted to do it.
I've been eating,
everybody does it and actually gotten sick.
I don't know anybody that doesn't like the cookie dough or doesn't try it when
they're baking.
And so that was the moment,
like kind of the light bulb for me that was like,
maybe this could be a thing,
maybe cookie dough could be a dessert on its own.
Um,
and so that started me on my quest to develop this brand and develop this
product that was completely safe to eat and bankable.
So you have the option to do both.
Um,
so then I decided to launch the business online to just test the market first
because I had no idea how to start a business.
Um,
you know,
let alone run a retail store,
which was the original idea.
So I launched it online to test it.
And then from there,
once that was successful and I saw that there really was this market of cookie
dough levers that I knew coming out of the woodwork.
Um,
I decided to open up the store in 2017 and that kind of catapulted the business
to the next level.
And I remember I ordered some for my team and we waited six weeks to get it.
I ordered it online.
Yeah,
you're so patient.
Thank you.
In a second.
Yeah.
I always,
I didn't get people that say no,
especially when we first opened like,
oh,
I waited three hours in line and I know,
you know,
they waited in the cold or they waited in the rain.
And I always tell people like,
thank you so much,
I'm so happy that we have such great fans and supporters and so many cookie
dough levers.
What are we gonna make today?
Okay.
So today we're going to make our,
one of our most popular flavors,
it is our Brookie dough,
which you guys have in front of you.
It's a combination of a cookie and a Brownie.
So that's why we call it the Brookie.
Um,
yeah,
you can't go wrong at all.
It actually started as a seasonal flavor.
So we have 20 different flavors at our shop.
And if for those of you who haven't been,
who don't want to wait in line,
it's set up like an ice cream experience.
So I wanted to create something that was familiar enough so everyone knows when
you go into an ice cream store you can get it by the scoop.
You can,
you know,
add toppings.
You can get it in a cup or a cone.
You can even make a milkshake out of it,
whatever you want to do.
Um,
but instead of ice cream,
it is all cookie dough and two of the flavors change every single month.
And we love to have fun depending on the season and trying new flavors and
always taking requests from fans about,
um,
you know,
what we should,
should have.
And we decided to have this flavor Brookie doe as a seasonal for the month.
It's just our chocolate chip and our Brownie batter swirled together in one and
it was immediately one of the most popular flavors,
which doesn't always happen with the seasonal cause.
Chocolate chip is like,
you know,
usually,
usually people go for the classic ones.
And we took a vote on social media and everyone wanted Brookie to stay on the
menu,
so we decided to keep it.
So now it's on our regular menu.
So I'm going to show you guys today how to make these two flavors,
how to combine them.
And then actually the Brookie doe originally since we opened the shop was a bar.
So it is a Brownie on the bottom,
it's chocolate chip cookie dough on top and then it's topped with chocolate
ganache.
So that was kind of the inspiration for the flavor in the first place.
Um,
so we're going to make the dough version,
we're going to make the actual Brookie,
um,
and the top it with chocolate ganache and then until you guys with all sorts of
sugar.
All right,
well I'll lake does that sound good?
Um,
thank you guys for having me.
Thank you for coming.
I hope you are ready to eat some cookie dough and have some sugar for breakfast.
Um,
I want this to be very interactive,
so if anyone has questions at any time,
grabbed the mic and ask away.
For me,
cooking and baking is an experience that I,
I love fell in love with because I got to share it with others.
I got,
I love baking and cooking with others in the kitchen and then sharing those
treats and seeing the smile that it puts on people's faces.
So please,
if you guys have anything,
want to get involved,
get your hands dirty,
let me know.
Um,
but yes,
like you said,
thank you for the introduction.
My name is Kristin Tomlin,
the founder and CEO.
I started the business in 2014,
um,
when I was still working full time at a brand consultant here in New York.
So my old job,
which I used to call like my real job and then this was my fake job.
Then now it's kind of switched.
Um,
I used to work in brand experience design,
so I was a designer for a consultant and,
um,
I got to work with amazing brands like BMW and Samsung and Walmart and I was
developing their customer experience.
So innovating that experience and really working through,
um,
how to stay new and different and I really use that expertise as I was
developing this brand to understand,
you know,
what are the unique points of the customer journey,
what are all the interactions?
Um,
so a lot of people assume that I,
you know,
went to business school or you know,
had this had investors or any sort of thing.
I had no idea how to start this business.
And I did it by trial and the only things I knew in the beginning were about
branding and about baking.
So I started there.
Um,
the first recipe I ever developed was our signature chocolate chip.
All of our recipes come from old family recipes that have been in my family for
years and years.
And then we've modified them to make sure that they're safe to eat,
um,
and that they're also bankable.
So should we get to it?
Awesome.
Um,
we're going to start with like I said,
chocolate chip,
which every one of our cookie doughs except for the Vegan flavors.
Start with good old fashioned butter.
We use 100% real butter.
Um,
we don't use any sort of margarine or you know,
Crisco or anything.
Fake butter is better always.
Um,
it gives your cookies and your cookie dough or really rich flavor,
which we like.
Um,
and also,
you know,
is for me,
makes every cookie you can really take.
I liked that buttery taste.
Um,
so that's exactly what we use.
We use unsalted butter.
So a lot of people don't know that actually salted butter typically has a higher
moisture content because of that salt.
And you don't want that moisture in your cookies.
You want it to be super fudgy and dense.
So don't use this
salt,
salt and time.
Do you also have more control over how much salt you put in your cookie dough,
which is exactly what you want when you're baking.
This has been soften.
So I've just left it on the counter to get to room temperature.
And this is going to be the base of what we're making.
So we would want it to be nice and smooth and creamy before we add any other
ingredients.
So I'm just going to leave it in here.
If you read a recipe that says cream the butter,
it's exactly what we're doing.
Um,
I always recommend using a mixer if you don't have a stand mixer or use a hand
mixer just makes your life a lot easier.
Um,
then it'll allow the flavors to really come together and make sure that,
you know,
the butter and the sugars are creaming,
which are incredibly important when you're making cookies.
All right,
so I have a question.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
um,
I've always,
like whenever I watch the cooking shows or the restaurant shows,
one of the most interesting things is like the sourcing of ingredients because
the chefs get up at like 5:00 AM and go to the,
well,
that's even pretty late to get up and go to the fishmongers by these fish that
you can ever buys a home cook.
And so what I'm wondering is like,
even with things like butter,
like there's a thousand different brands of butter,
how do I as a home chef or how did you,
as,
as in your role like source your ingredients and say,
oh,
this is the best butter for me to use.
Not that other brand of butter or whatever.
Yeah.
So a lot of testing goes into,
um,
all of our recipes and even from the beginning.
So,
um,
the type of butter that we use is an American butter.
It's not a European butter.
Um,
it depends on how much fat content you want.
Unfortunately,
we're not,
you know,
going to the farmer's market fresh and getting and getting the cultured butter
that's from,
from the,
um,
the farmer.
I wish we could,
um,
but,
but butter for me,
we know anytime that we can do local,
organic,
um,
you know,
we try our best and then it was just a matter of a lot of testing.
So there's a ton of different sugars,
a ton of different flowers that you can add in baking,
you know,
vanillas extracts,
all of that stuff.
And I'll talk through some of the importance of the other ingredients as we go
through it and why we chose certain ones.
Um,
but because our cookie dough is edible and Bakel,
it's a lot about the texture of how things come together when you're eating it
raw and when you're baking it,
it's not just one or the other.
And then also for us in any food business,
you know,
perishability is obviously something that,
we need to think about.
And,
um,
so making sure that our ingredients are top quality to make sure that they will
last for consumers in the fridge and in the freezer and all of the ways that we,
that we recommend cooking them or eating them.
So we got the butter,
the best part.
Um,
next we're going to add the sugar.
So this particular recipe uses a combination of white sugar,
which is granulated sugar and brown sugar.
For those of you who don't know brown sugar is white sugar with added molasses,
molasses,
do you have a darker sugar?
So dark brown sugar just has more molasses.
Um,
for this,
we're going to use light brown sugar.
Um,
and it uses 75% brown sugar.
So the brown sugar is typically what people mostly associated with eating
chocolate chip cookie dough.
It's that molasses,
the flavor that most people love and is,
you know,
super nostalgic.
So we really upped the amount of brown sugar that we use in this recipe,
but you 75% brown sugar and 25% white sugar,
the white sugar is going to help things spread.
Um,
and the brown sugar is going to be an acid in this recipe and it's going to mix
with a base that we're going to add later.
So cooking is a little bit of chemistry or baking at least is a little bit of
chemistry.
Um,
it's not as easy to just like dump a little bit of this and a little bit of that
in the substitute,
you know,
here and there.
Um,
so what we're doing is just creaming the butter and sugar.
We want to just let this go and get nice and smooth.
We want it to be all one color and all one texture.
Um,
the sugar and these little granules and what you want to do when you're making
cookie dough is you want to envision just coating each one of those little
things of sugar with butter evenly.
Um,
and just making sure it's nice,
smooth texture.
No question.
Yeah.
Since you've had so much success from your first store opening in 2017,
do you have any plans to franchise?
We get thousands of requests to franchise,
especially since we've opened,
which is amazing because it just means that so many other people you know,
relate to this concept and can see it being popular in their city or their town.
Yeah.
Um,
right now we are so busy and my team is so busy that I don't want to take a
minute of our time too to figure out the franchising.
I think we'll do a few more company owned stores before we actually franchise it
out.
Um,
this is very much like my baby and I have a very hard time letting go of,
you know,
handing it over to somebody else to just kind of run with it.
And that would always be my worry with franchising.
But I will never say never to anything.
I'm always keeping options open.
So I certainly think that,
um,
it could be a possibility down the line.
Okay.
So we got the butter and sugar.
The next ingredients that we're going to add our liquid ingredients.
And I want to talk about these for a couple of reasons.
One,
I'm going back to your sourcing question.
Our Vanilla,
we use 100% vanilla,
um,
pure vanilla extract.
It comes from Madagascar.
We have tested a ton of vanilla,
some from Mexico,
some from Tahiti.
I'm in Madagascar for us is really the best of the best.
So,
um,
I always recommend when you're baking and for at home chefs to go for the good
vanilla,
it will yield a better,
smoother flavor and you're in whatever you're baking.
Um,
and,
and typically a,
a bottle of it at home will go a long way cause you only use a teaspoon or a
tablespoon here,
there.
Um,
so it is expensive but it's,
it is really worth it.
We use even more vanilla in this recipe cause we liked that flavor,
how it mixes with the brown sugar.
Um,
so that is why this is liquid is Brown.
The other ingredient in here is our egg.
Most people assume that because our cookie dough is safety,
I'm just going to very slowly pour this in,
um,
to avoid it sprang up in my face and giving me an egg facial.
Good.
Um,
the other ingredient is the egg.
So most people assume that our cookie dough is safe to eat.
We just eliminate the egg and therefore you're good to go.
You can just eat it from the bowl.
That's actually not the case at all.
There are other ingredients in cookie dough that I'll talk about in a bit that
can make you sick besides just eating raw eggs in the United States.
As many of you know,
Salmonella would be the bacteria that you could get from eating raw eggs.
Um,
but our eggs are completely safe to eat.
They're good in this cookie dough.
And you know,
you could put it in your smoothie if you wanted more protein.
It's been pasteurized.
So that means it's been heated to a specific temperature to kill the bacteria
and then cooled back down.
Um,
and it retains its normal properties of an egg.
So if you were to stick this in a hot sauce pan,
it would make scrambled eggs,
which people are always surprised about.
Um,
but in cookie dough,
we don't want to make scrambled eggs.
We want it to be used as a binding agent.
So it's going to keep everything together.
It's also going to add some extra flavor that you otherwise would miss.
Um,
when I was recipe testing,
I tried every egg substitute out there and every single time it never stood up
to the real egg,
the real deal.
So I decided to scrap all of those substitutes and find an egg that was
completely safe to eat.
Um,
so that is our egg,
that's the liquid ingredients,
which we just added.
And now we're,
we want to just whip it until it's really light and fluffy to make sure that all
gets incorporated.
Um,
this mixer is great.
It's,
I'm not having to scrape it down at all because of the bowl is really high.
But sometimes when you're baking you might have to stop,
scrape things down just to get it all incorporated.
Okay.
So when I originally started the business,
I was,
like I said,
I was working full time.
Um,
and you know,
I think that,
I think I was nervous to,
cause no one else had really done this.
And we get so many people now that are like,
oh,
why didn't I think of this?
This is such a great idea.
Like,
you know,
everybody's been eating cookie dough.
Um,
but when I first started the business,
I didn't know,
honestly if it was really going to work,
I thought,
you know,
maybe somebody's this hasn't been done before because it can't be done.
Maybe people won't respond to it.
Well,
maybe there is this stigma that even if through education people won't be able
to get over the egg thing,
um,
or the worry of getting sick.
Um,
you know,
it's just a completely different model from an ice cream
store or a traditional bakery.
So it was difficult as I was like working on this business plan to try and
figure out,
you know,
how it would work and you know,
what would be popular and what wouldn't be popular.
Um,
so that's why I decided to start it online and just take baby steps,
kind of get my feet wet with the production and understanding what the market
looks like.
And luckily the market was amazing,
you know,
almost from the beginning.
I think the power of social media and you know,
people sharing what they're doing,
especially this like foodie culture in New York.
Um,
it really worked to our advantage and you know,
it's been,
it's been a really crazy ride but really fun.
Next ingredients we're going to add.
So it's a small amount of white questionable white powder.
It's all legal substances.
The first thing is really easy to understand.
It is our sea salt.
So we use sea salt.
It's a less refined salt so it has a little bit of minerality
in it.
Um,
which we like.
And additionally it is going to be baking soda.
So baking soda is the base in this specific recipe.
It's going to mix with the acid that is the molasses in the brown sugar.
It's going to create carbon dioxide.
Without boring you,
it will help your cookies rise in the oven.
If you put too much baking soda in your cookie dough,
it's going to taste like a bar of soap or like baking soda toothpaste,
which is the worst.
So you have to really balance how much you're putting in to make sure that it's
reacting,
um,
and make sure you don't taste it in the actual cookie dough.
And then the third ingredient,
um,
one of our secrets is a little bit of cornstarch.
So cornstarch is going to be also used as a binding agent and as 11 or so we
like our cookies when they bake to be extra super soft.
I'm not a thin crunchy cookie kind of Gal and you won't find thin crunchy
cookies that doe you will find nice and thick,
kind of crispy on the outside with that Golden Brown outside and nice and gooey
and shoe and the inside.
And that corn starch in the dough will allow you to get that soft bake cookie
texture.
Um,
so I'm going to just add these in now.
Can we just get together with your flower?
Um,
but I'm going to just do it first just to make sure it's really well
incorporated in the doe.
Um,
because it is a small amount of stuff.
You just want to make sure it's evenly distributed so that those reactions can
happen and all those flavors are really coming together.
So I'm really curious,
you're sort of targeting both,
you know,
making delicious when they're big and making them delicious as cookie dough.
And are there trade offs here where you could maybe make more delicious cookie
dough by not making them as good when they're baked or vice versa?
So when I was experimenting,
or actually when I was,
um,
well before I even came up with,
with the idea,
um,
there were specific recipes that we would make at home with my mom that were
really good as cookie dough and not as good as cookies or vice versa,
really good as cookies and not as good as cookie dough.
But my dad wanted the good stuff and I,
you know,
we always baked it and we always kept it raw.
And so we found a recipe that was the perfect mix of both.
And so that is kind of the recipe that we went off of for the development.
Um,
I think that there,
there could be ways,
depending on how rich you wanted or that consistency that you want it.
But for me what was important is to like really give people a full on cookie
dough experience.
So a lot of people when they eat our dough with a spoon there surprise like,
oh,
this tastes just like cookie dough.
And I'm like,
yeah,
it,
it is,
it's exactly what it is.
Um,
it's much more rich than an ice cream.
it's more dense.
So if you were to stick any of our cookie dough in the oven,
it would fake.
So I'm sorry.
It's tell people,
you know,
like if you save it for later,
if you can't finish it,
um,
it'll last in the fridge or the freezer.
You can always take it home and bake it or mix it with ice cream and you know,
that way you don't have to,
I was always the one like picking around the ice cream and just eating the
cookie dough out and then leaving the rest.
For my husband to basically have a pint of vanilla ice cream,
which no one actually wants.
So,
um,
next ingredient.
So I'm going to talk about the flower.
So as most people know,
um,
the eggs,
eating raw eggs could
be harmful.
There could be salmonella donate cookie dough.
We've heard all of that.
What a lot of people don't know is that raw flower could also harbor bacteria.
Um,
so if you think about it,
flower is a raw agricultural ingredients.
So it's grown in the field somewhere.
Um,
and there's really not a ton of control over what birds fly over or you know,
what critters may or may not crawl in.
And typically during the milling process,
when you harvest the wheat and you make it into flour,
and there isn't a step in that process which kills any potentially harmful
bacteria that those critters could have left behind,
which is gross to think about.
It then goes to,
you sits on your counter for six months,
that bacteria bacteria to harbor.
But as soon as you cook it,
you bake it,
you fry it,
you heated in a pan,
whatever you're doing,
that's the kill step that kills that potentially harmful bacteria.
So you don't even know if that,
if your flower head bacteria or not because you heated it.
But with the rise of people eating cookie dough and Brownie batter and cake
batter,
more people are licking the spoon and the bacteria is not from the egg.
It comes from the flower.
Um,
so that obviously poses a risk for,
for people at home.
Um,
so we did such an extensive amount of research.
We actually,
um,
we're one of the first people to bring this to the New York market.
So some of the large cookie dough and other manufacturers.
Um,
we're using heat treated flower.
When I started this business in 2014 but it was nearly impossible to get as a
small,
you know,
producer that might our minimum,
we didn't have room to have pallets and pallets of this not let alone go through
it all.
Um,
so that was one of the biggest challenges as I was starting the business is
finding someone,
a distributor to carry the product,
bring it in specifically for us so that we could make our cookie dough safe to
eat.
Um,
so the flower that we're using is a heat treated flower.
It's been through the process,
like the pasteurization process to make sure that all of that bacteria no longer
exists.
It's tested like the egg is tested before it comes to us.
Um,
and then again,
it's just like a normal flour so you can use it in your cookie dough and you
don't have to worry about getting sick.
Um,
the other unique thing about this specific flower is that we make our own blend
of AP flour.
So there are a ton of different flowers out there.
Um,
two basic ones mostly boils down to a hard flower and a soft flour.
And the difference between those flowers are about where they're grown,
when they're grown and when they're harvested,
and how much gluten is in those flowers.
So all purpose flour is a mix of both.
Soft flour is also known as cake flour and is really great for anything that you
want to be light and fluffy like French pastries or um,
or cake.
The other kind hard flower has a higher gluten content in is great for breads
and pizza dough.
It's going to give you that stretchiness that everyone loves to kind of bite
into.
Um,
and for cookies you just want to use a mix of both of those so that your cookies
aren't too dainty and crumbly and you also,
you know,
they're not too tough or stretchy.
So we mix our own proprietary blend of all purpose flour in house.
Um,
it was a process that we tested extensively,
um,
to have the exact texture that we want for the cookie dough and for the cookies.
Um,
so that is what we have here.
It is our blend of AP flour at t treated.
Um,
and I'm just going to add this in little by little,
you don't really notice any sort of difference in
the heat treated.
You might notice if you smell it a little bit of a,
a toasted flavor cause that's essentially what they're doing when they're heat
treating it.
Um,
but with the,
when it's mixed with all of the other ingredients and cookie dough,
you would never notice any difference whatsoever.
So add this little by little,
this is the final step.
Um,
this,
the recipe that we're making technically is in the category of cookies called
[inaudible] drop cookie recipe and a drop cookie recipe.
It's a recipe that most people make at home and most people are used to eating,
um,
or sneaking from the bowl.
What it,
it's the kind of cookie that you drop on a sheet and then bake.
You don't have to roll it out.
You don't have to cut it out.
You don't have to do all of these other things that some other cookies,
you know,
pipe or,
or anything else.
Um,
and drop cookie recipes are great because they're pretty easy to go together.
Once you have all of the ingredients measured out,
um,
which is,
you know,
half the battle,
you just throw it into mixer like this.
Similar to,
you know,
you always start with the fat in our case butter.
Um,
then you do sugars,
liquid ingredients,
and then dry ingredients.
Um,
and the good thing is it all comes together and you,
you really,
it's hard to mess up if you've measured correctly.
The only thing you can do is overmix it.
So once it's like good,
you can just keep going along with the process.
And especially once you add the flour in because the flower adds the gluten.
Once it's mixed,
you can just be done and you don't have to let it keep going forever and ever.
Um,
like you would potentially with a merengue or with,
you know,
whip cream or something.
You don't need to add any extra air because we want our cookies to be nice and
dense and fudgy.
Um,
and the more you mix it the more and activates that gluten and your cookies can
get tough.
Okay.
Did you have another question?
Right?
Yeah.
What's your name by the way?
My name is James.
Hey.
Um,
so like you've came in with the recipes from when you were growing up and also
through developing them,
you know,
as you started thinking about the business and you had the marketing knowledge
from your previous work,
you know,
but one of the things I've always heard is that the,
one of the hardest parts about building a restaurant is the actual like
business,
the accounting,
the are we actually making a profit right now?
Like,
Yo,
how do we control costs and get the right number of workers and so on and so
forth.
So where,
what,
like how,
have you just picked that up as you've gone along or did you,
did you have some previous experience in running business?
Um,
no previous business experience.
Luckily,
um,
my,
my husband,
um,
did go to business school.
Not that business school teaches you how to run a business.
Um,
he always says he's like,
this taught me nothing.
But it is helpful,
you know,
to kind of have a sidekick in that as at least Ben to school.
Um,
not that I didn't graduate and all of these things,
but um,
to be honest,
for me it was a lot of just figuring out as I go.
I always tell people,
especially new entrepreneurs like you,
there was never a point that you feel prepared or feel ready to start any sort
of business.
Like you'll never going to have it all figured out.
So just do something to move forward and you will learn if you are smart,
if you are a hard worker,
if you have a network of people that you can ask and honestly google.com is like
your best friend,
literally.
Um,
there's so many resources out there to find information.
And for me it was incredibly helpful to start with baby steps.
Um,
and so starting online first,
figuring that out,
learning,
you know,
hiring a few people and learning how to manage that and manage production and
ordering and online before I even opened the store.
Um,
and that's,
that's part of the reason why I launched online was because the t the thought of
opening up a restaurant in New York City without any business experience or
operation experience was incredibly daunting.
And I was looking at,
you know,
the investment was going to be insane and I didn't want to be one of those
businesses that opened.
And then or restaurants that you've see all the time that it's a great location.
It's a great idea.
You know,
maybe the execution is even pretty good,
but it just,
you know,
six months later the doors are closed because they just can't make it work.
It's incredibly difficult.
Um,
but I did use,
you know,
the experience I started launched in 2014 um,
and then,
you know,
didn't open the store 2017 so,
but even then when I,
when we first opened the store,
I had no idea about the popularity or like really an expectation.
I,
I thought it was going to be popular.
Like I told my old boss,
I was like,
maybe this could be the next big thing in desserts.
Like cupcakes have kind of come and gone,
you know,
this is when I was working on this idea in 2012 it was like,
so I was like,
maybe this could be the next thing.
Um,
and,
and I,
I didn't know.
So I had a story stories.
I had five full time people when I moved to the new store and they all were
working in the kitchen.
Um,
and one other like assistant who,
who did a little bit of everything business and you know,
kitchen and everything.
And then when I opened up the store,
so we,
we basically,
we're moving our kitchen and then we had this new front of House element.
And so I thought,
okay,
I'll hire five more people to help,
you know,
just work as hourly employees in the front.
Um,
and then all of us,
the people in the back and me included,
can pop in and out and like work up front and just make sure that everything's
running smoothly.
Like,
I'm fine,
you know,
checking people out or doing whatever we need to do.
My husband was like,
you can't afford five people.
You can only hire for.
So I'm like,
fine.
Okay.
I hire fire for.
Um,
and even then,
I mean we had,
we spent essentially all of the money that we had made in the first two years on
this new lease,
new build out,
new equipment,
new everything.
Um,
cause for me I was like,
I'm just going to go big or go home.
Like I,
I didn't want to keep doing what I was doing,
um,
with just the online orders and like,
you know,
this really small business.
I really wanted to see where it was going to go and just kind of give it my all.
It was,
it was incredibly terrifying.
Yeah.
Um,
and so we hired these four people and when we opened there was a line down the
block and I was like,
how did these people like what's going on?
You know?
And then I just thought,
I thought,
you know,
we had,
I think there was a news article and in New York magazine,
so I was like,
oh,
they probably learned about it through there.
And then as soon as these people come and go,
it'll be like quiet.
It was for like a small amount of time.
People like trickled in all day.
When we,
when we first opened,
we opened on Wednesday,
Wednesday.
Um,
I don't even,
Jeez,
that whole time is like a blur to me.
I don't think I slept for a month.
Um,
so we open on a Wednesday and then my family came to visit that first weekend to
kind of celebrate the opening and,
and my mom's typical fashion.
She had theater tickets and dinners planned and like all this stuff.
And on Thursday we opened up in the store was like slammed.
Wednesday,
we like ran out of a ton of stuff.
We were staying up all night trying to like remake it to open on Thursday.
Um,
and I called my mom a Thursday.
I was like,
cancel all your plans.
Like I need you guys to help work in the store.
Like,
I don't know what's happening,
but like,
I just need help and my family is there,
you know,
they're all bakers and cooks and like,
good Midwestern folk.
Like,
they'll,
you know,
roll their sleeves up and get their hands dirty anytime.
Um,
so they came on I think Thursday night and immediately I put them to work.
And so it was the four employees that I hired.
My Dad,
my brother,
my brother in law,
my sister,
two sisters,
my mom.
Um,
and we all took,
we,
we took turns like part of us were in the front part of some their back.
We were just making cookie dough,
you know,
my brother in law was did like dishes for eight or straight.
The poor guy love you James.
Um,
and my parents,
you know,
my dad's scooped cookie dough,
they have like carpal tunnel by the end of the weekend.
And they were like,
we have got to get out.
Um,
and that was the weekend that there were four hour lines down the block and
around the corner.
And we didn't know what was going on.
I mean,
that was just the very beginning.
We ran out of all of our ingredients,
like all of our cookie dough,
anything that was edible,
it was like gone.
And anything that you know,
was,
uh,
we,
we just ran out of every single thing that we had no flour in our flower.
You can't just like go to the grocery store and get our flour or our eggs.
So we had to wait,
this was the weekend,
so you couldn't put an order in until Monday.
So we've had to wait until Tuesday to get everything.
So I'm going to start on the next one while I'm talking.
Um,
so it was kind of,
to be honest,
a shit show.
Um,
but I learned a lot in those first few weeks and then we closed the store.
We had to,
because we didn't have anything to sell 'em for the first couple for a Sunday
and a Monday,
and that I put up as many ads as I could.
Um,
and then just,
I bet people would walk in and I'd be like,
okay,
do you like cookie dough?
Do you know anything about,
could you okay.
You can speak clearly.
Great.
Um,
are you available?
Great.
You have availability.
Can you scoop cookie dough?
Okay.
Show me that you can use your hands.
You're hired.
Like that was basically the process in the beginning,
which was,
you know,
worked for a time,
um,
and was great.
But obviously we've,
we've,
we have such a great staff now that we're like settled and established,
but that team of 10,
I guess,
or nine when,
um,
immediately to within the first,
like four weeks after we opened to about 60 people,
um,
we started running multiple shifts.
We were basically in the kitchen from,
um,
5:00 AM until midnight or 1:00 AM and then we were cleaning from,
you know,
two to four and then the team would come back at five and it was just like
around the clock.
And really,
um,
it was a struggle for many,
many weeks until we were able to get our facility in the Bronx open and running.
Um,
because not only did we not have enough
people,
we didn't have enough space,
like we didn't have enough refrigeration.
Um,
we didn't have enough of anything,
so we had to kind of move off site and immediately start looking at other
options.
Um,
what I'm making now is our Brownie batter.
So what I just put,
ed was melted chocolate,
semi sweet chocolate and butter.
That's going to be the base of this.
So this one is super fudgy,
really like a chocolate lover's dream.
Um,
and I'm just mixing it with the brown sugar again and the white sugar.
So this is going to be the base of that Brookie.
And then also obviously the Brownie part of the recipe.
Um,
this one is dangerous because this is a recipe that I can sit and eat like so
much of.
And suddenly I'm like,
what happened?
Like where,
who ate it?
Where did it go?
You'll like scrape the bottom of the container,
especially when it's nice and warm.
Um,
and it disappears in an instant.
So I guess my love for and baked things is like,
it goes far beyond just cookie dough.
I also love Brownie batter.
I love cake batter.
Anything that is like not fully baked,
kind of beauty in the middle is like my jam.
Um,
actually when I was babysitting,
I used to do ton of babysitting when I was [inaudible]
growing up.
Um,
and yeah,
I,
there were these,
this family I babysat down the street.
They have five kids and it was like madness at all times.
I usually had one of my siblings like with me and um,
and the one way to occupy their attention was to make brownies.
So I would get two boxes of brownies,
sit the kids down,
we would like have a mix,
one box would not have the egg.
And at this point,
this was so long ago,
no one really kind of knew about the flower thing.
Um,
and I would make one box without the egg and just put it in bowls and the kids
would eat,
you know,
the bowls and Brownie batter.
And then the other box I would actually make into brownies so that when the mom
came home there was like something nice and um,
you know,
fresh baked.
And also just to,
even though sugar probably wasn't the right thing to,
to give a bunch of rambunctious,
um,
rambunctious kids,
it was like just our routine.
Every Saturday or whenever I would babysit,
we would make two boxes of brownies.
And so this recipe,
even though it's a cookie recipe,
it,
it is very much like the Brownie texture and flavor.
It's super fudgy with that melted chocolate.
Other ingredients are going to be cocoa powder and then those learners again
and the sea salt.
So this was all going to go in the mixer.
I have a question.
Uh,
it seems like you've,
you've kind of built a cookie dough in New York that didn't exist before,
which is really awesome.
But now that you prove the concepts other,
I noticed the competitor down the street kind of sprung up.
So it,
has that changed your business at all?
Honestly,
no,
it hasn't really changed the business.
Um,
obviously we were the first of the co of our kind to,
to make this concept and show that it could really work,
especially in New York.
Um,
and for us we've been so laser focused and so busy on growing the business and
continuing to expand in a number of different ways that I don't have time to
like really pay attention to competitors.
Um,
of course,
like I'm aware that they exist.
And for me,
I think that this concept,
like I said,
how it could be kind of the next big thing and desserts.
I think that there's a lot of the pie to go around and because we have this
presence in New York,
um,
which is amazing,
I'm like encouraging other people and other cookie dough lovers to,
you know,
obviously follow their passions and if they think that they're um,
town would,
could use a cookie dough shop that only works better for me as I continue to
expand and more people learn about this cookie dough trend.
Um,
and if people always ask like,
oh,
are you worried about the people here,
the people there or these people are ripping you off or like they're taking your
this and um,
yeah,
I don't really have time to like,
what am I going to do copy the people who are copying me like a shittier version
of myself.
Like that is a terrible idea.
Like who has time for that?
Um,
so yeah,
we're continued to expand.
We are serving more than ever we have.
I don't know if you guys ever go to [inaudible] gains.
You have a couple of stands at Citi field,
which are really fun,
so you can get some cookie dough at the ballpark.
Um,
we also are doing a number of different popups this summer.
So we've got our camp cookie dough,
which is at Chef's club counter in Soho.
Um,
it is a summer camp themed cookie dough store.
So when we had this,
um,
this,
uh,
opportunity to do something for the summer there,
we thought,
you know,
obviously cookie dough is nostalgic and it brings everybody back to their
childhood.
And that's why I think people are like,
have this emotional connection to what they're eating.
Um,
people also have the same nostalgia,
especially in New York for summer camp.
So we thought,
why don't we just kind of blow this concept up and have all of the Di,
the dessert centered around childhood favorites.
All of them,
of course include cookie dough,
but all of them also include soft serve ice cream.
And it's a really fun experience.
Um,
we have a pop up in Montauk for the summer for anybody's east.
Washington DC and Chicago all the summer,
so
all sorts of fun stuff going on.
And we just launched our new baking kits,
so
we,
they're actually coming out in August,
but we just debuted them at fancy food the other week.
And um,
the three flavors for that are going to be chocolate chip Brownie batter,
which the two I'm making today.
And then sugar cookie and that mix,
it comes in a box.
I'm like this,
you just add two ingredients and then everything else is ready to go.
The nice thing about this product is that it's shelf stable.
If I were to ever start another food business,
perishability is like,
is so in refrigeration and freezing is like,
is obviously incredibly difficult.
Um,
so this is nice because it can,
um,
it has a long shelf life.
It can go in grocery stores across the United States.
Um,
obviously it has our name all over it and is like a brand,
a natural kind of brand extension.
Um,
in addition,
we continue to ship online,
um,
all over the United States and we have a pretty robust,
catering and event business in New York
and sorry,
um,
that we ship nationwide.
And then we also go to offices and do little cookie dough bars.
Um,
and then
at our store,
one of my,
like,
one of the most fun things about my job is just interacting with customers and
teaching people all of the things that I've learned over the years.
So we just started this,
um,
baking school program.
It's called the cookie academy.
Um,
and you can take cookie dough making and baking classes in our store.
So I think we're almost good.
What I'm going to do here is just turn on this,
I can get it.
Okay.
So I've got
some on going to make here is the good notch to top this Brookie.
So what we've got is we've got our Brownie batter,
which is nice and gooey tastes exactly like Brownie batter and we've got our
chocolate chip cookie dough.
So in order to make the Brookie what we would do,
which we're not going to do,
right,
the second is we would take this,
we would press it down in a pan and we would bake it.
So the bottom is a full on Brownie.
Then we would add a layer of chocolate chip on top of that once it's cooled,
and then stick that back in the oven until it gets nice and gooey and it's not
fully baked.
And then it gets topped off with a chocolate ganache.
So we're going to do the ganache element ganache.
Sounds fancy.
It's not.
It's very easy.
Um,
but it's really also super delicious.
So all you're gonna do is you're going to heat up heavy cream.
If you can do it in the microwave,
you,
um,
it makes it even easier.
Okay.
Um,
and then you're just going to pour it over the chocolate chips and let it set
and then we'll whisk it together.
Um,
but to make the actual Brookie flavor,
what we do,
since we scooped the cookie dough out of what looks like gelato containers,
we would add dollops of both of these different flavors in the same container
and then kind of swirl it around.
So if you guys can tell from the little jars we have in front of you,
um,
that we like being able to see the chocolate chip cookie dough and the Brownie
batter cookie dough.
So it's not like a full Nick's,
it's really like a swirl technique.
Um,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to fold in.
I'll do it in here because it's,
it'll be a little bit easier to see.
Um,
I'm going to just take some of this Brownie batter and just add a few dollops in
here and then we'll just swirl it around and we'll have some
fresh cookie dough
when you do the little cups.
Do you do equal parts chocolate chip Brownie?
Yeah,
we do.
Um,
those cups are,
you know,
everything's filled by hand,
so they might have like some of them I'd have a little bit more of one of the
other,
but we try to do it really evenly and I only,
it started one or two times and you get this like nice ribbon technique and we
would leave it just like this.
Um,
if we were going to bake this into cookies,
all I would do is refrigerate this cookie dough,
put Saran wrap over it,
stick it in the fridge,
um,
for as long as I can at least 24 hours.
And then I would just scoop it out with a cookie scoop right on.
Um,
a sheet tray and three 50 in the oven for about 10 minutes.
They make really delicious cookies.
Um,
so that's what we got.
We got our Brookie doe and then let's see how we're doing with this heavy cream.
Okay.
I'm just going to get this to a boil
and then turn it down.
You guys have any questions in the meantime?
Anything else I didn't cover?
Hi.
In this sort of health crazed market.
Yeah,
Audi,
you sort of combat that or uh,
help people to limit the amount if that's something you are doing.
So obviously,
you know,
I get that question a lot.
Like everyone's like,
oh,
it's,
it's not just like gluten free or Vegan this and trying to be healthy.
People are just trying to eliminate,
you know,
fats and sugars and all those things from,
from their diet.
Um,
certainly we have gluten free slavers and Vegan flavors and all of that which
are equally as delicious.
Um,
but I also think that there's a moment in life to treat yourself and to have a
little bit of fun and indulge in something that makes you happy.
So you all work very hard.
I work very hard.
Everybody like has,
you know,
lives.
There's a lot of stuff going on in the world that is not pleasant.
And so if there's a moment that you can just put a smile on your face and treat
yourself to whatever makes you happy,
maybe that's a yoga class,
maybe that's a spoonful of cookie dough,
maybe it's an ice cream cone.
Maybe it's none of those things.
And it's like your own personal choice.
That's what I'm all about is like just making sure that,
you know,
we're putting a smile on your face and allowing you to indulge in something that
you really love.
So even with all the healthgrades,
like trust me,
I have to go to soul cycle like way too often too.
Cause I get cookie dough all day.
Um,
but I do think that there's a moment where you deserve a little treat and
something
just smile.
So
you so much for sharing your story of course.
Was that tipping point or that moment where you were like,
I need to make this my full time job and it's really time to leave your brand
background.
So I,
so this is just really coming to a slow boil 'em and as soon as it you see those
bubbles,
you can take it off and all I'm going to do is pour it over this chocolate,
um,
and just let it sit for a second.
Um,
so I was working full time.
I was living the consultant life,
which is just a difficult life.
Um,
because you're traveling,
you know,
you're on the site with a client,
etc. Um,
and so when I started this business,
my boss,
my boss knew I was starting it.
And,
um,
and so once things were kind of taking off,
I went to him and I was like,
Randall,
I was like,
I dunno what the is going on,
but I just feel like I need to dedicate more time to this business and like
trying to figure it out.
And I don't know at what point,
you know,
people like quit their jobs or don't,
but like,
I don't know that I want to come.
I took it.
It was very,
it was very conflicting for me.
And so,
um,
he was so nice and so encouraging.
And so originally I,
um,
went down to working two days a week and I had a really flexible schedule,
which helped me dedicate more time to the business.
And I also,
you know,
it was only on a one final client commitment.
Um,
and as you know,
that started wrapping up.
It like still,
even working two days a week was,
was too much.
And I found myself just really wanting to work on the business and it taking up
every,
every hour of my day.
And my poor husband,
you know,
hadn't slept either.
So,
um,
so I just went back and I was like,
look,
I,
as much as I love my job and as much as this has been such an amazing
experience,
I'd been there for five years.
Um,
I feel like now's the time to kind of take a step and see where this goes and
has never looked back since then,
but it wasn't easy.
It was difficult,
very difficult.
That was about six weeks after I had launched online.
So,
um,
yeah.
Um,
what about people were kind of skeptics that think this is a fad and how do you
keep it relevant?
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So I always tell people,
I obviously did not invent cookie dough.
So cookie dough has been around for a very,
very long time.
And cookies in general are such an American dessert.
Um,
you know,
that people that have grown up with for,
as you know,
since the 18 hundreds,
it's like when the chocolate chip cookie,
you know,
really came to be.
Um,
and so I'm not pretending like I'm created something new,
but what I think I'm doing or I'm making a huge mess,
that's what I'm doing,
um,
is,
is kind of reinventing it and making it new,
indifferent,
um,
and serving in a different way obviously.
Um,
which I think has a lot of legs because the nostalgia factor.
So,
um,
it's rare that,
you know,
you find something that's so many people can relate to on this like emotional
level because it reminds them of their mom or their grandmother and nostalgia
goes a long way.
Um,
but I also recognize that,
you know,
fads come and go and desserts come and go.
And so I think it's continuing to listen to our customers and continuing to
innovate and find new ways to expand the brand.
And,
um,
so I'm not really concerned.
I don't think cookies are going away anytime soon.
I don't think cookie dough is going away.
So I think as,
as long as we're continuing to,
you know,
stay relevant and be new and different and,
um,
innovate the experience,
I think that cookie dough can go along way.
Well,
thank you so much for joining us.
Um,
it has been so great to have you here and we cannot wait to eat this,
Dan.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.